c'est un gigantesque projet d'extraction
d'or qui pourraient être relancés en
guyane un projet qui a pour nom montagne
d'or et qui pourrait causer des dégâts
environnementaux importants selon les
opposants
en cause le cyanure une substance
chimique utilisé dans l'extraction
aurifère est hautement toxiques
[Musique]
la cyanuration ou lixiviation est un
procédé permettant de rendre soluble
lors dès les années 1980 cette technique
industrielle était utilisé en guyane
une première en france c'est un procédé
qui est connu depuis une décennie et qui
est utilisée déjà aux états unis mais
qui effectivement est appliqué pour la
première fois en guyane et et même en
france puisque actuellement aucune
installation de ce type ne tourne en
métropole en france le cyanure a
officiellement remplacé le mercure dans
l'extraction aurifère en 2006 les eaux
contaminées par le cyanure sont en
circuit fermé et contrôlé mais l'éthique
ne sont pas à l'abri d'une rupture en
1995 un barrage minière a baissé dans
huit années en amérique du sud
déversant du cyanure dans le fleuve et
ses kibo c'est à une véritable
catastrophe écologique que l'on s'attend
guyana après la rupture durant la nuit
de samedi à dimanche dernier du barrage
qui retient les effluents des cuves de
la mine d'aubin un accident qui ne
servira pourtant pas de leçon car cinq
ans plus tard en roumanie un bassin de
substances chimiques se fissure
des milliers de poissons morts et un
taux de seniors 800 fois plus élevé qu'à
normal la mine d'or de rulhe au nord du
pays restent comme la plus grande
catastrophe écologique en europe de
l'est depuis tchernobyl selon wwf
c'est vers 10h qu'on a vu les premiers
poissons morts il y en a eu de plus en
plus alors que les gros agoniser les
petits sont morts tout de suite cette
catastrophe va polluer la tisza pendant
des années
le procédé de cyanuration dans
l'extraction d'or continue d'être
utilisé dans le monde entier et les
catastrophes se multiplient comme monde
paul et au canada en 2014 et ses
catastrophes écologiques inquiètent la
population guyanaise d'ailleurs 69%
d'entre eux sont opposés au projet
montagne d'or en 2018
un projet qui risque de faire grincer
des dents à l'heure où l'écologie a plus
que jamais son mot à dire
[Musique]